this library is full of historic  treasures  the trinity library in dublin ireland  was founded in 1592  its most famous area is the long room  this 213 foot room houses 200 000 of the  library's oldest books  the room is lined with marble bus  many of great philosophers writers and  people who supported the college  the long room is also home to one of the  last remaining copies of the 1916  proclamation of the irish republic the  trinity college harp which is from the  15th century  and the book of kells an illuminated  manuscript of the four gospels that is  from the 8th century  it is the largest library in ireland and  as a copyright library it can obtain  books and materials published in ireland  for free  it is the only library in the country to  hold this right  [Music]  you